it's working out okay we've got almost
600 affiliates so stations all over
America I decided I'm gonna start
carrying the Dave Ramsey show all over
America that's a lot of stations
America's big man Ramsey's everywhere
you can just look at all gone I am
driving it with pride baby he was doing
the show in 92 yeah that's a time ago
when along came the station out of
Nashville looking for a show if you're
gonna air in Nashville you've got a slot
that's prime and so he got syndicated
and then 500 something times he asked
him if he'd seen a man with so much debt
in hand and he said listen I've helped
some folks all over this here land Rams
everywhere man Rams everywhere man
all stations he's there
the dead
call these hashish
and Randy's in
listening
don't Minnesota Buffalo Boise Muncie
Robbie Wichita tell some on top - Sante
possib Ana spoke in Atlanta
we off all the more freshmen and
and Ramsey's every
all sections
reason
cause he's had a stand man
in Austin Austin Austin Houston Dayton
brief
Bakersfield opa-locka fix her pants her
father's burgstahler City Kansas City
[Music]
all stations East a man please begin
- and man
[Music]
find a station near you
[Music]
you